I have been thinking about resuming my
learning of coding and web development
etc for a while and when I was younger I
would sort of start it up and I'd find
some place online to learn a little bit
and then it just kind of get tired of it
because the layout wasn't good or I felt
like I wasn't really able to measure my
progress or whatever else and recently
hacksaw Academy got in touch and offered
me a free trial free account on their
website and offered to sponsor a video
and I've been messing with it all
weekend and trying out a bunch of
different projects as you can see here
I've completed none of them but I've
tried out a lot of different projects
and I really really liked it and the
best thing about it is I'll open up the
landing page project here let's see if I
can we start from the beginning i will
restart one of the great things about it
is very very often when i've used other
websites for learning coding and web
development etc it's sort of tedious to
look in sort of a live way at what the
code is and then what the result of that
code is etc and one of the really great
things is that the hacksaw academy site
is laid out in a super straightforward
way where you sort of have the lesson up
here in the top left and in the right
you've got three panels the HTML panel
the CSS panel and the javascript panel
and i'll just show you like for example
for this very first basic HTML lesson i
can copy this HTML code and after
pasting it in the HTML panel I
immediately see here in the output panel
what that looks like as another example
CSS you can then take CSS code and again
this is just example code and sort of
teaching you how to use the system and
after pasting it in the CSS panel which
normally would be contained in a live
web site in a different file all
together you'd have to be maybe flipping
back and forth between a number of
windows that immediately takes effect
here in my lower left panel and then the
same thing applies to javascript which I
can
take here copy and paste into the lower
right javascript panel and what that
does is it actually pops up a message
when I click the text in my output panel
so I really really like that it's just
super-easy to go through and to
understand the relationship between HTML
CSS and in this case javascript and
hacksaw Kadim e not only do they have a
whole bunch of different projects that
you can you can look at and try
different levels of detail really really
wide variety of things they also give
you a 14-day trial that you can enroll
in they have ten thousand registered
students the first project is free and
if you like it and want to continue its
10 bucks a month for unlimited access I
also really like that there are some
websites where you are basically paying
a per project fee and on hacksaw Academy
for 10 bucks a month you have access to
all the projects you want that I really
really like so I encourage you to check
it out use the link in the description
to this video let me know what you think
of it and I am I'm REE committed i would
say at this point to really resuming
learning to code and it's not like i'm
looking to take over a coating of the
david pakman show website but i find it
to be a really really great skill to
have and it is learning another language
in many ways and that I really like